[موسيقى]
سلافيانسك بعد القرم على ما يبدو هناك قام
مؤيدون لموسكو بما فعله نظرائهم في القرم
قبل اسابيع استولوا عمليا على المدينه
التي تقع شرقي البلاد على المباني
الحكوميه فيها وعلى تلك التابعه للامن
الاوكراني واقاموا ما تاريس على مشارفها
وطالبوا باجراء استفتاء لتقرير مصيرها لم
يمر الامر من دون اشتباكات بين مؤيدي
اوكرانيا هناك ومناصري
روسيا بلغ التوتر هناك حدا دفع وزير
الداخليه الاوكراني للطلب من سكانها
البقاء داخل منازلهم وانا يبرحها او
يقتربوا من نوافذها جاء ذلك بعد اعلان
الوزير نفسه عن شن حمله لمكافحه ما سماه
الارهاب في المدينه التي لا تبعد اكثر من
150 كيلومترا عن الحدود
الروسيه لم يقتصر الامر على سلافيانسك بل
شمل مدنا اخرى تعرضت مبان حكوميه فيها الى
هجمات من مؤيدي موسكو امر وصفه الرئيس
الاوكراني بالحرب على بلاده بينما ادرجه
محللون في سياق مسع روسي لتحسين وضعها
التفاوضي مع الغرب في مؤتمر يفترض ان يعقد
حول الازمه الاوكرانيه يوم الخميس القادم
ويتوقع ان تطالب موسكو خلاله باصلاح دستور
اوكرانيا لمنح مناطقها الشرقيه قدرا كبيرا
من الحكم الذاتي وهو ما ترفضه كيف
وحلفائها
الغربيون على ان خيارات كيف ومن ورائها
الغرب تظل مقتصره على الجانب الدبلوماسي
والعقوبات الاقتصاديه وترى واشنطن
والاوروبي ان هدف موسكو من زعزعه
الاستقرار في شرق اوكرانيا هو ايجاد ذريعه
لها لارسال قوات لحمايه الناطقين بالروسيه
هناك تماما كما فعلت في القر ولا حل في
الافق للرد على ذلك سوى تشديد العقوبات
الاقتصاديه على روسيا لكن هذا بحسب كثير
من المحللين سيقابل بردود فعل روسيه اشد
تبدا مما يسمى سلاح الغاز لا ينتهي بما هو
اهم وهو قضم مزيد من الاراضي الاوكرانيه
وفرض وقائع على الارض لا تغيرها مؤتمرات
ومناشدات
دوليه